من داخل هذا المركز وهو مركز موحد لعمليات
عوده رايدي الفضاري انا وعلي وتحديدا خلف
الشاشه التي تحمل رواد الفضاون بينهم ايضا
رائدي الفضاء ريان وعلي وتحديدا ايضا من
خلفي تماما هناك فنيون ومهندسون من الهيئه
هيئه الفضاء والاتصالات والتقنيه يقومون
الان في هذه اللحظات بتحليل المعلومات
وكذلك المعطيات التي تصلهم من فلوريدام
وهي المعطيات والمعلومات الاخيره
للحظات الاخيره للانفصال هذه المركبه التي
نشاهدها الان من محطه الفضاء الدوليه ولعل
الصوره التي تظهر لنا الان وهي الجزئيه او
الفاصل بين المركبه مركبه دراغون وكذلك
محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذه المركبه هناك
مراحل سوف تمر بها حتى تتمكن من
الانفصالها من المحطه وهناك ساعات ودرجات
حراره مختلفه وسرع عاليه حتى تصل الى كوكب
الارض عموما هذه المراحل وتفاصيلها وكيفيه
انفصالها سوف يكون معي المستشار في هيئه
في الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء وهو المهندس
ماجد المشاري مرحبا بك مهندس كنت معنا في
بدايه الانطلاق والان للعوده لعوده هذه
المركبه المركبه سوف تتم او سوف يتم
انفصالها تقريبا في تمام الساعه السادسه
وخمس دقائق بتوقيت المحلي السعودي مراحل
سوف تمر عليها ودرجات حراره عاليه وسرعه
لا نتوقعها اكثر من 28 الف كيلو متر في
الساعه
بدات اجراءات عمليه الانفصال من اكثر من
ساعه
وتشمل فصل جميع الانظمه الميكانيكيه
والكهربائيه التي تربط بين مركبه دراغون
ومحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تمهيدا للانفصالها الكامل باذن الله
الساعه السادسه وخمس دقائق بعد عمليه
اكتمال الها اجراءات الانفصال ستبدا مركبه
دراغون بالتحكم الكامل بالابتعاد عن محطه
الفضاء الدوليه باستخدام محركات الدفع
وانظمه التحكم الخاصه بها وعند وصولها الى
مسافه امنه سوف تبدا عمليه الدوران حول
الارض وفي نفس الوقت النزول في المدار الى
اختراق الغلاف الجوي بسرعه ما يقارب 27
الف كيلو متر في الساعه
وتتعرض اثناء ذلك الى درجات حراره تصل الى
2000 درجه مئويه وفي هذه اللحظات
قد ينقطع الاتصال بالمحطه الارضيه من ست
الى سبع دقائق ثم
باذن الله فور تجاوزها لهذه المرحله
ودخولها الى الغلاف الجوي
سيتم ابطاء حركاتها بالمظلات المخصصه سؤال
الان مرحله الفصل حتى وصولها الى الغلاف
الجوي كم سوف يقضون من الوقت داخل هذه
المركبه والسؤال اخر ايضا لعله
نجاوب عليه او تجاوب عليه مع السؤال الاول
الذي سالته هل الان المرحله الصعود هناك
دوافع تدفع هذا هذه المركبه ولكن الان
العوده الدوافع فقدت او لا يوجد نتكلم عن
هذه المرحله التحليليه نعم الوقت الذي
سيقضيه رواد الفضاء الى حين اختراق الغلاف
الجوي قد يصل الى عشر ساعات تقريبا طبعا
نحن شاهدنا في رحله الانطلاق احنا
استخدمنا صاروخ لانه نحتاج انه نتحرر من
الجاذبيه لكن العكس الان راح يكون راح
نستخدم مركبه دراغون انظمه التحكم الخاصه
فيها اضافه الى الجاذبيه الارضيه اللي
ستكون الى الى صفنا
وانظمه التحكم ومحركات الدفع موجوده في
مركبه دراغون وايضا المظلات الموجوده كلها
باذن الله ستساهم في وصول امن ان شاء الله
الى سواحل الشرقيه لولايه شكرا لك مهندس
ماجد المشاري وهو مستشار في هيئه السعوديه
للفضاء وبينما ايضا تحدث عن هذه المعلومات
وتحدثنا هناك درجه الحراره قد تصل الى
2000 درجه مئويه حتى نزول هذه الكبسوله
ايضا هنا فنيون ومهندسون يقومون الان
بتحليل هذه المعلومات وهذه الارقام التي
ترد الى الرياض وتحديدا من مركز الموحد من
فلوريدا الى الرياض الذين يقومون الان
بتحليلها وايضا اعطاء بعض المعطيات وبعض
التعليمات التي يكونوا بالتواصل بين رياضه
والسلامه للجميع من مركز العمليات الموحد
في الرياض مراسل العربيه نصفيا شكرا لك
ولضيفك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات